hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
there's something that is very common in
physics as well as in
other areas of science namely course
graining
this is something that you do when you
have a situation where there are
many things going on perhaps at a
microscopic level
and you're not keeping track of all
those microscopic things right you don't
know exactly where the molecules of air
are in the room or in a cup of coffee or
something like that
so you take many different possible
arrangements of the microscopic things
and you group them together and you say
like this set of arrangements is going
to count as one big
macroscopic configuration this
difference that's going to count as a
different thing
now it turns out that in representative
democracy
something very similar happens right you
have many many people
many many citizens of the democracy and
it's
usually impractical to imagine that all
those people will directly vote
on every single issue that comes up in
the country that's called direct
democracy
it doesn't really work very well it
hasn't been tried that often
but instead what you do is you make a
republic a representative democracy
right you
have the individual people vote for
representatives
the representatives are supposed to
represent their interests in the
legislature or as the president or
whatever
this raises an interesting problem how
do you go
from the set of all the different
opinions and feelings that the citizens
have
which might be a huge different sort of
heterogeneous set of ideas
and goals and desires and coarse grain
them
into a small number of people who will
actually
travel to the capital and sit in the
legislature or the parliament or what
have you
so today's guest is jordan ellenberg
jordan is a well-known
mathematician who specializes in
algebraic geometry
he's the author previously of how not to
be wrong
a new york times bestselling book and he
has a new book coming out called
shape the hidden geometry of information
biology strategy democracy and
everything else
so what jordan and i are going to talk
about he has many different things going
on in the book
but we've picked out this theme of how
you coarse grain your democracy and in
particular
how do you draw boundaries for
congressional districts right this is
the problem that we face
in the subject of gerrymandering
gerrymandering is the idea that
a party in power can fiddle with the
shape of different districts to
guarantee that
it gets more seats in congress than it
deserves in some sense
now as soon as you say that you say well
what do you mean deserves
and it's not clear we have to actually
think about the politics of this
the political philosophy how should we
represent
the goals desires interests of different
people in the government
that's fine we're not going to talk
about that today that's a very important
politics and political
philosophy question but there's also a
math question
given some particular goals how do you
make them
happen mathematically and even more
importantly at a legal level
how do you know when someone is bending
the rules how do you know when someone
is cheating
turns out you can say well consider the
space of
all possible shapes of districts in a
state
can you say that the particular one the
legislature has drawn
is unfairly biased that's a good
rigorous math problem and talking about
it
gets us into interesting questions in
geometry but even more interesting
questions in randomness
even though the question we just asked
seems pretty straightforward
you're comparing the specific map that
people have to draw the districts
to the set of all maps you can't really
analyze a set of all maps it's too big
instead what you do is a random walk
through the set of all maps
that gets us into questions of how you
do random walks and markov chains and
different algorithms for searching the
space so it's a wonderful
example of how not just physics but
other areas of human inquiry
bring up these very intricate very
interesting math problems we're
using politics here really as an excuse
to talk about math we're not talking
about politics that much in this episode
but the math that you need to do
politics well turns out to be
fascinating
in its own right so with that let's go
jordan ellenberg welcome to the
mindscape podcast hi thanks for having
me
so we're going to be talking about
gerrymandering and the role of geometry
in math and gerrymandering it's a
slightly political topic but you're a
mathematician
uh as a professional here so what why
don't you just for the sake of the
listeners
say what you do for a living like how
what kind of mathematician
are you so i'm primarily a number
theorist
which means that i study these questions
that mathematicians have been
wrestling with really since there was
such a thing as formal mathematics these
questions if you write down an equation
and does it have solutions in whole
numbers and if so what are they
um that is something we somehow still
don't know that much about
all these many millennia later although
we certainly know more than we did at
the outset
um but maybe more specifically on what's
called an arithmetic geometer so
over the especially in the last 100
years or so we've come to see that these
questions which seems to be purely
numerical or algebraic
actually have like a very very serious
geometric
understructure and that's very much the
way that the subject is seen
now in 2021 well that was one of the
interesting things uh
that i learned from talking to emily
real uh who we just had on
a few weeks ago and we haven't had that
many mathematicians on
yeah we haven't had too much math but
now there's like a surfeit of
mathematics i don't know what's going on
here but
uh she said she comes i guess from the
opposite side she's a topologist
and she keeps finding as apologists do
these algebraic structures
in the study of how you can deform
things from one to another
yeah that's so interesting because i so
she is so fully manifested herself as a
category theorist that i think of her as
that and i actually didn't know that she
started in
topology although that's certainly the
origin of that subject
yeah no that's exactly right so despite
all this and despite the fact that you
know math one of the most
pure abstract uh philosophically
elevated things we can think about
uh you did i don't think that you
testified in front of the supreme court
but you at least signed a brief the one
in front of the supreme court right
exactly right so sort of when the
supreme court is considering
a big case especially a case with a lot
of technical content of various kinds
um they get briefs for all kinds of
specialized groups but typically kind of
this gerrymandering case
this was the case there's briefs from
historians briefs from political
scientists briefs from lawyers briefs
from community groups
interest in the case um i think this is
as far as i know the first case in the
history of the supreme court where there
was a mathematician's brief
and you're oh for one the mathematicians
did not get the answer
that they were hoping for right so we
will have to wait another 200 years for
the next case this mathematical to come
before the court
okay so even our record we might have uh
listeners who are not familiar either
with politics or the united states or
lingo or anything like that what do we
mean when we use the word gerrymandering
right so the fundamental idea is this
that in the united states
um in both the us congress and in state
legislatures
um we elect the people who make the laws
from geographic districts we cut the
state
up into a set of districts in wisconsin
uh there happened to be 99 of them
um sort of a weird number i know but
it's in the constitution that
every senate district has to be three
assembly districts so it has to be a
multiple of three that's sort of
constitutionally mandated
um and um you know you break the state
up into these districts and then each
district
elects a legislator by majority vote
um what we have and what in some sense
we've known for a long time but has
really like
come to a kind of apex now is that this
process of
choosing how you execute this division
how you divide
the state up into districts which seems
kind of technical and boring and i guess
you just draw some lines and do it
that turns out to have an absolutely
huge
effect on who sits in the legislature
or rather it has a huge effect if you
work hard to give it a huge effect and
that process is called gerrymandering
that process
of partisan actors motivatedly drawing
the lines
so as to ensure that their party is
advantaged
um in in the election and i think you
know they're sort of sort of best summed
up
with a popular uh description of the
practices saying instead of
uh the legislators are choosing their
voters instead of the other way around
yeah i mean and it's all based on the
fact or it arises from the fact that for
whatever reason
we choose to allocate our
representatives geographically in some
sense right we
the starting point which we're not even
going to question in this discussion is
you divide the state up into regions of
geography
and then within each region you vote for
who wants to represent you
right and one thing i learned writing
about this is that there's lots of
places that don't
do it this way you know in hong kong
there's a constituency like just for
teachers to run for the seat you've got
to be a teacher there's a teacher's seat
there's an engineer's seat there's a you
know like mother you took on functional
constituencies
um you know in iran there's a seat just
for jews in ireland there's a seat just
for graduates of the university of
dublin there's lots of ways
you want to hear my craziest idea about
this sure i thought it would be i mean
i thought it would be cool if like maybe
we shouldn't really do this but like
imagine if there was a seat
imagine if you broke the age ranges up
into bands of equal population it was
just like okay there's like a congress
person
there's a representative of people aged
40 through 51.
you know you could argue that those
people across the state have a lot more
in common with each other politically in
terms of what their priorities are what
their needs are
than people of very different stages of
life who happen to live
50 miles apart in the same professional
respect well it's interesting to think
about the future because i can imagine
that 200 years ago
geography was just the way that you
could easily slice
this pie but these days we can do better
yeah so i'm interested to see whether or
not i know that there are a lot of
clever
maybe overly clever voting schemes on
the market but
we'll see whether any of them actually
catch on in real elections
uh but one of the one of the instant
worries you get to and we'll probably
get to this in more detail but when you
have this scheme where you divide things
up geographically and then just have a
majority vote
is that so if you have a state with 99
representatives let's say
uh and 60 of the state
as you very nicely put it you know
there's the orange party and the purple
party so you're
not associating these with any real
parties here in the united states so 60
are orange voters 40 or purple voters
and in this weird idealized situation
where
every district is exactly sixty percent
orange voters and forty percent purple
voters all of the representatives would
be orange even though forty percent of
the
voters are purple so there's sort of a
built-in amplification
of tiny um edges in the voting right
yeah this is you know i sort of set this
up as a thought experiment
in the book but you know it's also
called massachusetts that's another name
for this phenomenon right in
massachusetts is a state
which there are republicans in
massachusetts not even that few i think
it's about a third to 35 percent of the
state so that's pretty significant
um if i remember correctly there hasn't
been a republican member of congress
from massachusetts since 1996
right i mean it's been it's been nine
democrats for a long time
and that's actually not because of
gerrymandering that's because
the very nature of geographic
districting as you say
um in a state that's two-thirds
democratic there's not going to be very
many republican neighborhoods certainly
not like entire
republican patches of the state big
enough to be a a congressional district
right so i guess what i wanted to get on
the table there was just that eve like
you say even forgetting about
gerrymandering
this whole idea of just having
geographic districts and voting in them
can lead to big distortions if you
compare it to just proportional
representation from inside the state
right but this is a this is one of the
reasons this question is so interesting
is that you really find yourself saying
what does it mean
to be representative right so
one i mean it's very natural to think
that the
the right notion of representativeness
is as you say what's called proportional
representation which means that the
proportion of legislators from each
party
uh is roughly the same as
the proportion of voters for that party
maybe not maybe not on the nose but that
a deviation from that is understood to
be some kind of failure of
representativeness
um that's a system a lot of countries
have it is definitely not
the american system and it never has
been so you know look i always say like
people write about this in terms of
democrats and republicans but like you
know sympathy for the libertarians man
like
year in year in out about one percent of
american voters vote for a libertarian
congressional candidate now there's 435
members of the house if you believe in
proportional representation
you think there ought to be a few
libertarians sprinkled in there and how
many are there
zero because there's no such thing as a
libertarian
congressional district or even a
libertarian neighborhood it's kind of
fun to imagine what it would look like
isn't it but
yeah as far as i know it doesn't exist
well yeah because of this
effect that our voting system or our
system of apportioning representatives
turns up the contrast knob right so a
slight
uh advantage in the electorate gets you
a huge advantage
in the chamber and if you're down there
one percent you'll you'll
be normalized down to zero very very
quickly but one thing i mean we're sort
of imagining this is sort of some kind
of like
system with noise in it if you're in a
state like wisconsin where i live
now you're in california which is a very
different story um
but in wisconsin where uh the proportion
of voters
who vote democratic vote republican is
pretty close to
50 50. um but because of that
you know the political conditions are
quite different when the mood of the
state is more democratic and the mood of
the state is more republican so
under what you might call a normal
system even with single-member
geographic districts
um there would be uh there would be
swings there would be years when
democrats held the majority in years
where republicans held the majority so
at any given time
that majority might be pretty big in
favor of one party or the other
but it would switch back and forth and
in some sense
you know there is um there's some
political justification for that there's
some political justification for saying
like
you know it's good for the legislature
some of the time
to sort of have like a healthy majority
of one party so that things can get done
yeah and then if the voters don't like
those things that are done well then it
switches right and then
exactly i mean you're bringing up the
fact that uh we don't agree
ahead of time on what we want a fair
outcome to be
in any of these situations right there's
there's competing interests that we have
to get to but
so just to be super clear i think that
you said it already in some sense but uh
what how gerrymandering works is sort of
to
advantage one party over the other
taking advantage of the fact that
the representation within each district
need not be
uh reflective of the state as a whole
exactly and if you're the person drawing
the maps and in many states wisconsin
being one of them
the people who draw the maps are the
legislators the very people whose
electoral fortunes
are at issue so it's like hard to
imagine a worse feedback loop
from the point of view of um you know
conflict of interest
right um you know to put it and you can
draw lots of
charts and pictures and graphs but the
fundamental way it works is pretty
simple
the party that you don't favor you try
to cram
all of their voters into just a few
districts you try to create
uh districts which are absolutely
dominated by the opposing party because
by doing so you're sort of using up
their voters
yeah so and and uh if you if you like
wasting their votes on a few districts
that they'll win by a lot
leaving the rest of the state composed
of more districts where you win by a
more modest
amount and that's exactly what we see in
wisconsin and just to be clear
this happens everywhere like well at
least in the united states like this is
this
uh procedure of drawing weirdly shaped
districts and you can show pictures and
sort of laugh at how weird they are this
is really really common as far as i can
tell
well a couple things i want to say about
that one it doesn't happen everywhere
because not every state has the
procedure where the legislators
themselves are the ones
drawing the map to determine their own
fate so there are states like iowa is
one where forever they've had sort of
some panel of retired judges
draw the maps and nobody's gonna say
they're perfect
but they're not people whose like
literal job is to be political
operatives for a political party by the
way when i when i say that
when i say that the legislators drop
maps that's not even quite correct it's
like literally people who work for the
state party
yeah like not even elected officials but
just people whose entire
job is not to represent the public but
to represent the interest of their party
that's who's actually sitting in the
room drawing the maps so
you know one thing i like about this as
a sort of place where there's a
possibility for reform
is the system we have is like literally
almost the worst
possible thing we could have
you know is the system of just asking
some retired judges to draw maps perfect
no but it's way better than what we're
doing in a lot of states
um so this then raises the question of
how and now the math begins to come in
uh
one question i guess the first question
we might address to ourselves is
do we is there a way of characterizing
how unfair
a particular set of maps is and so what
do people say about that
yeah and actually that's a great
question because what it turns out
if you try to say what's fair like
what's the perfect math what's the math
that's truly representative
i don't think that's a question that has
a mathematical answer actually i don't
think it has a philosophical or a legal
answer
yeah either and then you might say well
so what the hell are you gonna do
well i think the question of what's
what's fair
is very hard but i think the question of
what's unfair
is much easier and that's a crucial
distinction we're not looking for
perfection here i think
eliminating gerrymandering saying we're
going to turn the gerrymanderer knob to
zero
that's impossible that's an unrealistic
hope and it's not even clear it makes
sense
right to sort of like it's like saying
i'm going to eliminate all trace of bias
from my thinking and be like perfectly
rational
no but you can look for the worst
offenses
right again which we can see right here
on the ground in wisconsin and
and there's a few other states but um
but one thing i want to say that's
really important is that a very
common and historically grounded myth
about gerrymandering
is the thing that you said that it has
to do with funny-shaped districts
this this in fact it's right there in
the name the sort of the word
gerrymander comes from this famous
political cartoon
uh about a map drawn by elbridge jerry
whose name i am told was actually
pronounced
gary but that ship has sailed like
everybody calls it gerrymandering so
sorry to the descendants of elbridge
gary but we're calling him jerry
um you know this kind of crazy
districting of massachusetts that he
engineered as governor
which they said looked like a salamander
um
and so it was the gerrymander this was
the origin of the name and you know now
too there's like
there was a famously crazy looking
district in pennsylvania that was warmly
called goofy kicking donald duck
because of the way that it looks but
here's the thing
um nowadays when these maps are not
being drawn by some kind of political
savant like sitting with a giant map
like rolled out on a big table but are
being done by machine
if you say i want a map that
advantages my party by a huge amount
and it looks fine the districts are
shaped like you know roughly
rectangularly and nice
you can do that in wisconsin we have
exactly that if you looked at the
map we had before 2011 which was drawn
by a court
and the map we had after 2011 which was
a highly gerrymandered map drama
political operatives
you wouldn't be able to say one of these
has funnier looking districts than the
other they look about the same
so if that was ever a good measure of
gerrymandering it no longer
is we can't detect it with the naked eye
we have to do something more
sophisticated
we're all increasingly concerned about
our privacy and security online and that
includes you
a virtual private network such as
nordvpn
is for you i love nordvpn for when i'm
traveling if i'm using wi-fi
at an airport or in a restaurant you can
protect your data from hackers
and nordvpn will automatically block
malware sites
and botnet controls and it has online
security for your kids so it protects
their online privacy as well nordvpn
will block
phishing sites and it has next
generation encryption
furthermore nordvpn is the fastest vpn
out there and incredibly easy to use
it's just one click so go to https
nordvpn.com mindscape that's nordvpn.com
mindscape
or use code mindscape to get a two-year
plan plus a bonus gift with a huge
discount and if the product is not for
you there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee that's nordvpn.com
mindscape uh that's very interesting
actually because i hadn't quite
appreciated that so you're saying that
you know the
the use of computers and our modern
data-driven techniques
allow us to gerrymander in a way that we
don't know it when we see it we have to
be a little bit more sophisticated about
what it means
for the map to be tilting in one uh
direction or another i mean you don't
know when you see it
when looking at the map you may know
when you see it when you're like why do
i live in like a swing state that like
has lots and lots of members of each
party but
year in and year out the legislator has
like a huge near super majority of one
party like there you can see it right
you can see the effects
you can't see on the map so there was
one uh effort
to characterize the unfairness of maps
that you talk about
before sort of discarding is not the
right way to do it which was the
i guess the efficiency gap how many
people's votes
are wasted and you know that does have a
superficial plausibility to me
yeah and i don't discarding is too
strong i think there's been a sort of
as in any science area of scientific
progress there's going to be an
iterative thing where we sort of develop
like better and better measures you know
you think of a measure and then you're
like well here's some of the problems
with it
um in some sense here you see the
difference
between scientists and politicians
because politically you should probably
sort of
choose one thing and be like this is it
if you argue against this you're wrong
but a scientist you know we're not
inclined to do that we're always
inclined to look at whatever it is we're
using and be like could this tool be
made better what are the issues with it
what are the edge cases where the tool
doesn't work so well
so um i think it's a bit it can be a bit
frustrating to the lawyers who are like
i thought we were arguing on this now
why are we arguing on that
measure which i i very well understand
but again
because my framework is not let's make
it perfect but let's
root out the absolute most grievous
gerrymanders
the good news is that we have a bunch of
different measures and on a map like
wisconsin
they all agree right it's not hard it's
not hard to see that something like
very dirty is going on and literally any
reasonable measure you can think of
well you know light the right like the
big red blinking light
why don't you explain what the
efficiency gap is because i think it's
it's at least a good example of sort of
an attempt to
make the voting fair yeah so the
inefficiency gap
um what it measures is it says it relies
on this notion of a wasted vote
where a wasted vote is one of two kinds
it's either a
vote for the party that loses in a given
district so it's a vote that somehow
doesn't
go towards getting you a seat or it's a
vote for the winning candidate
above that 50 threshold that you need so
it's any votes
above or beyond um 50
and that would capture something very
very true about the way gerrymandering
works
which is that if you're trying to be
efficient with allocating your votes
like if you could just draw
draw the districts completely not
geographically and just choose the
voters you'd be like
especially if you like knew how they
voted you would say
after the fact you would say like okay
i'm gonna make a bunch of districts
where 50.001 percent of the voters
are mine 49.99 percent of the voters
are yours uh and i'm going to win them
all and if the
political nature of the state means that
actually there must be a lot of your
voters somewhere i'm gonna put them all
in one district
i'll put them all in one district and
then i win the rest um
that would be very efficient where every
time you win you win by only a little
you're kind of getting a lot of seats
with very few extra voters at the margin
um and so i think that that notion of
efficiency gap is very simple to compute
and it captures something of um
it captures something very real about
how gerrymandering works and attempts
you know you can very clearly see
empirically that
it's a lot bigger in states where the
legislature is drawing the maps for
their own benefit than it is in states
where there's some other system in place
whether a citizen's commission or a
judge's commission
or whether it was drawn by courts after
a battle or what have you
and then one of the arguments against it
though if by remembering correctly
is that if you did have this ideal
situation where
every part of the state had exactly the
same representation
60 orange 40 blue
that would not even if you just did
everything completely evenly
uh that would not get a good score on
the efficiency
gap measure but there was no
gerrymandering going on
yes exactly i think the one if the flaw
of that measure
is that in the end it does kind of
seem deposit that there's some right
answer to how many legislative sheets
there should be
given a certain popular vote it's not
proportional representation but in some
sense it's in the same genre as
proportional representation
yeah um and i think and you know by the
way this is something that
there is definitely argument about so i
don't want to sort of say that my view
on this is the only one
um but it is the view that you know
plainness went forward with
the supreme court case of rujo versus
common cause is that
you know the opposite of gerrymandering
is not hewing to some
standard that you think of in advance
about what the number of seats should be
the opposite of gerrymandering is not
gerrymandering the opposite of
gerrymandering is what would have
happened
if those maps had been drawn by a
neutral arbiter
of some kind good so now the math is
going to start
coming fast and furious because your
your question now has shifted to the
realm
of the ensemble of all possible maps we
could imagine drawing of congressional
districts and asking questions about
that and
this is get this is what gets
mathematicians very excited right i mean
this is where there starts to be some
like
really interesting math and where i
think a lot of mathematicians have
gotten
involved um you know i could name a lot
of names moonducing at tufts justin
zalman
mit jonathan mattingly and greg
hirschlag and duke
west peggy carnegie lots of people who's
been whose day job
is like proving theorems i've gotten
interested in this
because you know it wouldn't be great if
we were also civic minded that we like
worked on problems just because they're
important
uh but no i mean there's lots of
important things in the world we work on
them when they're important and
mathematically interesting i mean
so that this speaks to like our special
skills to be honest or not
usually called for in most political
questions
um so exactly right what you'd like to
say
is well what if the map had just been
drawn by somebody who didn't care which
party came out
ahead let's say a map plucked at random
from all the possibilities
that there are that would certainly be
like an unbiased neutral
uh nonpartisan way to do it um that
sounds very appealing but then you have
like a big
problem which is the set of all possible
districts things the space of the state
is like
absolutely unfeasibly uncomputably huge
i mean i couldn't even tell you like
how many there are um the ways to cut
wisconsin up into 99 pieces
right that's a lot well you're slightly
aided by the fact that there are these
voting wards
uh thousands of them but still they're
discreet units
so at least it's not literally an
infinite number right but the
the question is how would you divide up
the voting wards into a set of
congressional districts
right i think there's about 7 000 awards
in the state of wisconsin so if
uh right so if you think about how many
ways there are to sort of partition
7 000 things into 99 pieces that is a
very very very big number
even if you start to oppose requirements
that each piece should be
connected in wisconsin constitutional
you're not allowed to have districts
that break up into several pieces
although in some other states that is
allowed
even so you you simply can't
write them all down on a sheet of paper
or store them all on a hard drive and
then pick one
at random you have to do something uh
you have to find some proxy for that
um and the way we typically do that is
by this mechanism of what's called a
random walk
right um i mean it's something that
people in physics do all the time right
monte carlo simulation there's something
that happens all the time in physics um
yeah no we know better than me what's a
context where that would be
random vlogs are surprisingly important
for for many reasons but i just want to
before we get to that
i want to home in on one question that i
had so i mean i can imagine
the math problem of given a state
with a certain shape divide it into
geographically pretty regions with
approximately the same number of people
in them
uh that sounds both easier
and very different than imagining all
the ways to partition the state into
geographic regions and
find a typical one i mean maybe the
typical one looks kind of like
weird and fractal you know is there is
there a reason why we don't just
pick the geographically pretty ones uh
minimum
area curves or something um and by the
way i want to say that's not
a hypothesis it's good intuition if you
actually could choose a uniformly random
one the boundaries probably would look
really bad and
fractal you can sort of see that in
experiments like much smaller cases mike
lorenzo knight knows a lot about this
actually so
so um so right
you know one thing i like about this
problem is that
it is a math problem mixed with a
political problem and a legal problem
and you can't really separate the
strands from the other so there is like
a history of work that treats this just
a mathematical problem
in other words like let's mathematically
sort of define what it means for
districts to be nice and try to figure
out like what would be the nicest
uh division of the state into
equi-populous regions and you get these
you know you get sort of nice polygons
you know with like straight line
boundaries
and then you like show this to like a
politician or a lawyer and they will
like laugh until they pee their pants
right right because because this has no
bearing on anything that's politically
feasible
or anything that respects like actual
political divisions in the state and
actually you know it's
i mean these are people who like live in
real communities and actually you know
we have in wisconsin
we have a people's districting
commission which has no
legal powers but the governor made one
anyway just to sort of say like this is
what it would look like if we drew a map
and you know i fit this out with their
hearings and it's pretty cool like just
you know they hold a hearing and when
people call in it just like regular
people from these places in wisconsin
it's like
you know my community is like split down
the line between two assembly districts
why it makes sense for us you know we
have these specific needs having to do
with like this particular lake and its
health and like why are we not why do we
not have like one assembly member who
like cares about this i mean so
um those kinds of considerations if
you're actually doing it
um you know i i want to say
i think the system we have is bad but if
you want to know why would there even be
such a system in the first place it's
because in principle
a representative is actually supposed to
be listening to the people that they
uh purportedly represent working for
those people like not working for a
political party they have to be a member
of so
there is like a reason this is thought
of as part of the
political process so if you talk to
political science people or elected
officials
they'll say there's no way we're going
to let a computer draw the map
that's not nobody wants that voters
don't want it politicians don't want it
judges don't want it that's a
non-starter and that's what happens if
you try to treat it like a math problem
without treating it also like a
political legal problem
on the other hand having now sort of
crapped on my own tribe
um if you try to treat it as just a
political or legal problem
and not a math or geometry or
quantitative problem
your results are going to be just as bad
and traditionally that is what we have
done
yeah that's fair enough but the nice
thing about the ensemble approach right
is that these other
considerations like you want uh it's not
you're not picking
a completely random um partition of the
state you want things to be
geographically continuous for example
but also you know you want to
give representation to minority groups
and and you know
maybe have some sensibleness to the way
that uh people are divided up and
in principle that can be included in how
you
define your ensemble is that right
exactly so you know the ensemble just
refers to like
that's like what we uh call like a set
of things when they said it's kind of
big like dress it up and like make it
sound fancy right so it's
uh you just have to say the same thing
but in french yeah and then that sounds
like bigger and more technical
um so yeah you have this big uh you have
this big
ensemble of randomly generated maps and
it's certainly not all possible maps but
it's um a set of maps for which for
reasons we can talk about if we want
are seen to be fairly representative of
the set of all possible maps
and we can build in certain biases that
we want we can build in
hey i want the districts to be like
roughly round if you want that
you can build in hey i want the
districts not to cut the county lines if
they don't have to which wisconsin is a
constitutional ask i mean different
states have different
criteria of what the districts should
look like um basically you build in
everything the districts are supposed to
be like except you don't build in oh and
by the way
i want my party to have like five more
seats that would be for
fair and then you look at your like
whatever your 20 000 maps or a hundred
thousand it's easy to make lots and lots
um and you see you look at actual
election results and say like okay if
the awards were arranged into districts
in this way
what would the outcome have been how
many seats would each party have in the
legislature and
invariably you just get a very nice
roughly gaussian curve a bell curve just
like you always get you do any kind of
experiment like this right you sort of
see that there's
very typical outcomes and then there's
very atypical
outcomes and in states like wisconsin or
north carolina
or maryland where they have heavily
gerrymandered maps the outcomes from the
actual maps
are way off in the tail of the
distribution they're very visible
outliers and so it gives you a really
nice clean
signal of this is not something that
happened by chance
much as the people who do the map may
want to tell you that um
no this is an absolutely like grievous
thumb of the scale in favor of one party
and against the other oh i think this is
very very important because
probably if people hear that we're
talking about gerrymandering and math
and geometry
they might leap to the idea that you're
using geometry
to draw the map but that's not what
you're doing you're suggesting that yeah
no human beings will draw the map we're
going to use
math to judge how fair how typical or
how
how
non-distorted that map actually is in
terms of
comparing its actual results to what
typical results would be is that right
exactly math is the geometry is the
referee here not the player
good and so we need to construct
ins or at least deal with this idea of
an ensemble of maps
uh to figure out what would be fair in
the world of all the maps and
and by the way is it is this one of the
i hypothesize that this is one of the
gaps between professional mathematicians
and civilians that
that when a regular person talks about
you know a random number if you say you
have a random number between zero and
one
the instantly in their mind in my mind a
number appears .71835
whereas i think mathematicians actually
just instantly go to the ensemble or to
the probability distribution or
something like that like
converting the phrase random element
into
really what you mean is an ensemble or
sort of a random variable is really a
whole ensemble is that
a helpful step into thinking more like a
mathematician
yeah when i think you know the word
random is of course like one of those
heavily overloaded words you know to
like my kids it means a song i don't
like
you know to to uh
and often you know to a mathematician
random
something that's completely
deterministic could be random it's just
random and all the probability is
concentrated at one point right so it
literally just means something
uh it just means the outcome how would i
even describe it in words sean this is
hard actually
um maybe it means something in which
chance
could play some kind of a role but it
doesn't mean for instance like you know
if you flip a coin and it's weighted so
that
two thirds of the times it comes heads
and one third of the time it comes tails
uh a civilian as you put it would
probably say well that's not random it's
biased in favor of heads a mathematician
would say oh of course it's random it
just has a different probability
distribution
so we would say sort of like it doesn't
have to be even
anything that is subject to chance in
whatever way you would consider a random
variable
that's right okay and so but the
particular issue that we're facing with
here
as you've already made very clear is if
you're trying to compare the actual map
to an expectation of over all the
possible maps you could reasonably draw
that that ensemble of maps you could
reasonably draw is far too big
so rather than and sorry i guess maybe
something to get right here is um
there's an np hard problem
sneaking in here we did have scott
aaronson on the podcast a while back and
we talked a little bit about np hard
problems but
remind us what those are and what the
specific one is
yeah so the uh if you were to
um say i want a way of provably
drawing and now we've got to slightly
hit the curve a uniformly
random map which means that every
possible map is
equally likely yeah um
you have to formalize it a little bit
more than that to sort of get it into
like literal things to improve theories
about complexity theory but essentially
that problem is known to be np hard what
that means is you know complexity theory
is this very funny subject where
um there's this whole class of problems
and what the kind of theories people
prove is like
problem a is as hard as problem b and
problem b is at least as hard as problem
c
and problem c is at least as hard as
problem f and etc
in turn at least as hard as problem a
okay but
proving that any individual problem
actually is hard and doesn't have a fast
algorithm to do it
is like completely out of reach so the
whole outfits could come crashing now
tomorrow right so
somebody could be like i found a fast
algorithm for like one of these problems
and now they're all easy okay
nobody thinks that's actually gonna
happen but it's it's a very funny
subject in that way so
and be hard kind of refers to this class
of problems that
are so to speak the hardest problems and
we
think the case is that they're all hard
rather than that they're all easy
yeah but we don't actually know and
so but we can approximate them often so
an np-hard problem
takes a lot of steps to solve but then
there's a somewhat independent question
which is
how efficient could an approximate
solution be is there is there a general
theory of that
yeah um i don't think so and i've been
to a lot of seminars about it and
and i mean this is definitely and this
is a little bit outside my field i'm not
a complexity theorist but like i said
there's so many interesting talks in
like the sort of like machine learning
and optimization group of wisconsin
uh which is very closely tied to the
math department um it does seem like the
way the subject is going
is to say like i'll give you an example
traveling salesman problem
very famous empty heart problem uh you
want to find the fastest
route you know you have like 100 cities
or something and you want to sort of
draw a path through all of them and you
want to find the fastest one
now that is an np hard problem to do
that provably and find the very fastest
one
and you can say like okay great we
proved the theorem like that's really
hard
meanwhile while you prove that people
are just doing it right
because you know the engineers while you
do that they're like yeah but
i'm content to get a solution to write
an algorithm which
with probability 99.99 finds a solution
that's at least 99.99
as good as the optimal one so while
you're over there proving your theorem
like i'm just
making the path half the people who used
google maps to get to the conference
where you show that you cannot solve
this problem right although people don't
usually
plan a hundred conferences in a row
their entire itinerary through the
entire thing i would not
actually have no idea how google maps
performs if you give it like a hundred
destinations
and ask it to chart them out and do them
all um
but so so i do think the way that field
is moving
is towards like you know what problems
can we
solve approximately and ideally provably
with high probability but maybe
probably with high probability it starts
to get a little philosophically fuzzy
what it is that you're doing
um and so we want to talk about random
walks now
well i think that's exactly where we are
so just to just to sort of catch our
breath because
we should pat ourselves in the back for
getting this far so we have this problem
of
we want to compare a given map that some
people in a smoke-filled back room came
up with
to what to expect in the ensemble of all
the fair maps but the ensemble of all
the fair maps
is way too big so what you're going to
tell me is the way to
sample from it but unbelievably in my
mind
is to pick one and then start changing
it in little random ways
exactly so that so what you do is you
start with some given map and even it
could be the map that we have right now
it could be this gerrymandered map
and say let's do something to it but
something pretty simple
like the set of things again the seven
possible things we could do to it is
pretty big so i'm going to be very
restrictive about what i'm allowed to do
um i'm going to say you're allowed to
take two districts that are adjacent
and move a ward on the boundary from one
to the other
okay i'm going to be honest with you the
best possible algorithms are a little
bit
more complicated than this and an
interesting way it makes them work
better but i can't do it on audio
okay you gotta look at the book and look
at the picture they should buy the book
anyway
yeah i wouldn't but
the basic idea would look kind of like
this
um rather than sample from every single
way you could possibly change it
you restrict just these very natural
local changes if i take a
word that's on the boundary and shipped
it to the
district on the other side of the
boundary um
and doing moves like that and then you
say okay i'm going to do like
10 000 of those moves each time choosing
a random some word on the boundary
remember the number of words is not very
big the number of words is about seven
thousand so choosing a random thing on
the seven thousand is k
that you can definitely do yeah um
and it turns out that just doing a few
moves like that
um actually can sort of get you around
the space
pretty well and sort of get you a lot of
very different looking maps you know the
analog i always like to bring up
is the number of ways a deck of card can
be you
cards in the order is pretty big it's a
number called 52 factorial
um you are not gonna be able to list
them all
and pick one at random so then you might
say well i guess the problem of like
putting a deck of cards in like a pretty
random order
must be an unfeasible problem but it's
not a feasible right i mean you do it
all the time
what do you do you just shuffle the deck
we know that there's an algorithm for
that
so how does that work because a shuffle
is a particular kind of change
that you're allowed to execute but
unless you're some kind of
sleight of hand genius like there's a
shuffle that you do is not going to be
exactly the same every time there's some
amount of randomness where there's sort
of some small set of possible shuffles
that you could execute depending on
exactly what order when you like
like when you flip the cards down
um and it turns out and this thing you
can prove theorems about so my
undergraduate advisor percy diaconus is
a very
together with dave buyer it's a very
famous theorem called the seven shuffle
theorem
it's one of those theorems it does right
what it says on the can yeah it says
that
seven shuffles which is a very small
number
is essentially enough to put a deck in
like extremely close to uniformly random
order so this is the magic of the random
walk with these that
choosing from a very limited menu of
possible changes
and choosing one of random and just
repeating that
has a wonderful power to allow you to
explore a space
that you simply can't see from afar you
can't see it
globally it's like wandering around in a
landscape where
in order to have a map of it you would
have to sort of have a balloon and be
like 10 000 feet above it but what if
you don't have a balloon
all you can do is kind of like wander
around
at each at each moment sort of choosing
whether to walk north west east or south
northwest did i say the mall yes okay
good um
but if you do that that's actually like
not a bad way to explore a whole space
if you do that for a long time
you actually probably will get
everywhere give it enough time
so i don't know if you know but if you
go to vegas and play poker
um many of the good poker tables will
have
automatic shufflers so the human being
is not involved but
if they don't they the casinos do not
let the dealers actually shuffle the
cards in an ordinary way because they
are good enough
to more or less put it in whatever order
they want it to be so
the way that they shop is to just
scatter the cards face down on the table
and swirl them around with their hands
before gathering them back up because
that's at least a little bit less
controllable but i would think that
doing that
once would not be enough is that right
my intuition would be that you'd want to
do that several
times is that right or is once well if
they're really scattered all over the
place right
then it's not just like a single shuffle
where it's just you you pick two and and
move them back in and then you cut the
cards etc so i think it's good enough
for government work or for vegas work
yeah
okay good so with that footnote on the
table um
so just to be super duper clear we're
doing a random walk but we're not doing
a random walk
through the state assigning things to
different uh
congressional districts we're doing a
random walk through the space of all
possible maps
and the nice thing is there's sort of a
obvious
local way to do that you have a map and
you pick one boundary on the map and you
sort of mess with that right
right except as i said it turns out that
there's a better local way to do this
but it's something like that yeah
slightly more sophisticated yeah
and this is a move that happens again
and again in the history of geometry and
it happens again and again in the book
is that
you think you're dealing with one
geometry but then to really solve the
problem you have to kind of go
one level up and it's kind of meta and
think about the geometry of geometry
it's like the geometry of
the space of all possible ways to cut
the state up so that is definitely a
leap
into abstraction and you know in a in a
book like this that is not for
professional mathematicians or supreme
court justices or
professional gerrymanders you know we
kind of lead up to it i mean this is at
the end of the book but it is uh
but it's a move that we constantly make
going from the sort of very concrete
geometry of two and three dimensional
objects that we can understand
um kind of building our intuition there
and then
lifting that into geometrizing
uh entities that are much more abstract
and yet somehow can be approached using
the same techniques
well one obvious question is i mean
convince me or at least assert very
strongly that this kind of procedure
will be a fair sample of the space of
all the maps i mean isn't it possible
there's just some maps
we never get to by starting with one map
and making little local deformations
so that is absolutely possible in fact
um
we don't even know that the space of all
district things is uh what's called
connected which means it's possible
there's some other complete undiscovered
country
of ways to district the state uh
that you never get to um you can choose
for yourself how much of a problem you
think of that as being for me it's not
and i'll explain why
because if you start with the map that
the legislators drew
and you mess with it and basically every
single thing you do to it
rapidly dissipates the partisan
advantage that it has that's a pretty
strong indication that that particular
map
uh was cooked in other words like you're
right that we may not provably know
whether it's an outlier among
all possible maps what we do know is
that it's an outlier in its own
neighborhood
like even things that are very much like
it still are like
not as incredibly favorable to the party
through the map as
the map that we actually use so that to
me is a very strong signal
yeah and i think that this makes sense
to me as a physicist in sort of
entropy terms in some sense right i mean
there are a lot more equilibrated
configurations
of a set of uh molecules than there are
low entropy out of equilibrium
configurations so
even if you start with a weird
configuration and mess with a little bit
you'll push it much closer to an
equilibrium one because there's just so
many more of them right
right if you write the headphone cord in
your pocket it's gonna get tangled up
because
instead of untangled states it's like
pretty small you know i actually
mentioned this exact
example in my book and i'm like man even
for like readers now or
under 30 do they know what a headphone
cord is this all right and then like you
know 10 years from now people will be
like
what is that what does he mean like what
is the thing that you would have
no but okay so yeah
i am i don't want to let this go by
without
taking advantage of some of the work you
did for the book digging into the
history of the idea of the random walk
because it's fascinating like all these
history things are always very very
fascinating so when you say
i start at a point in some space and i
walk randomly in some direction
that doesn't sound so hard but uh you
know in fact it it
crept up on us quite slowly like
mosquitoes were a
big player in the first random walks
yeah i knew almost nothing about the
history of this so i had an incredibly
fun time
learning about it and it's one of these
things that is surprisingly common in
the history of
science where somehow the world is ready
for a certain
idea so this idea of the random walk
kind of comes up
in a bunch of different contexts at once
and it first comes up
um well maybe not quite chronologically
first but as you say
um ronald ross who is the fellow who
discovers that mosquitoes are driving
the spread of malaria
he's the person who discovers the
transmission mechanism of malaria and so
he becomes very interested in like
well what's the right mitigation like
you can't kill all the mosquitoes right
that's another good example of a problem
that's infeasible because there's too
many right
but you can kind of clear some small
area of mosquitoes and then what you
want to know is like
well how long does the area stay
mosquito-free like how good of an
intervention is that because of course
the mosquitoes are going to get back in
from elsewhere after you clear the area
so to understand that you want to know
if a mosquito starts in sort of some
stagnant pond where it's born
like how far is that mosquito typically
going to migrate
in a certain amount of time and because
mosquitoes are not really very goal
directed
beings that's a random walk problem
because each day the mosquito is going
to do something but as far as we know
the mosquito doesn't have particular
aims like it just kind of like
flits where it will like day by day and
so its progress
is sort of a random walk towards the
landscape and you know ross
i mean he's a fascinating character i
literally had never heard of before i
started writing this book i mean this
very famous
figure in the history of medicine he
actually kind of secretly like really
wanted to be like a mathematician and
also a poet and was kind of like
you know bitter about his life in
medicine and sort of like felt like it
wasn't really like that great of a thing
to do even though he was the
super famous nobel prize winning uh
doctor um so he would like write poems
about
how unappreciated he was is that anyway
it's a whole thing it's a whole thing
um but he recognizes that this
mathematical problem is a critical
import to understanding the spread of
disease and actually he comes to the
same lewis exposition of 1904 which i
think among physicists is famous because
it's where poincare gives his sort of
famous speech about like
maybe we're going to have to change
physics maybe things look different near
the speed of light and things are going
to have to be like modified so that the
laws we know are only approximations i
mean this is uh
um but he's also there um
and he sort of he sort of talks about
how like
well they expected me to give a speech
about medicine but what's really
important is the math so i can't even
talk about math and no one understood
like he was that kind of guy he was sort
of a difficult character yeah
um um so he asks uh he asks carl pearson
the statistician carl pearson
if he knows anything about it because he
recognizes he can't really figure out
analytically how to solve this problem
um and then pearson writes a letter in
the
in the letters column of nature and
pearson coins the term random walk
he tells ross like i'll put it in nature
but i can't mention the problem is from
biology because
none of the mathematicians will work on
it because they'll be like we don't do
biology problems this is considered very
disreputable right so we made it an
abstract problem
uh and put it in nature um
and rather quickly a physicist lord
rayleigh
sort of explained like oh i actually
know how to do this i did it like 20
years ago for
an application in acoustics so this is
sort of like in england
how this notion of the random walk uh
was first analyzed the two-dimensional
random walk of the mosquito moving
around in the landscape
but what i discovered is that at the
same time almost at the same time
um you know i think if as you say
civilians if people who are not
mathematicians actually know the phrase
random walk
they probably know it from the title of
burton malchio's book a random walk down
wall street a book i really love
um because it's one of the most it's
probably like
the giant bestseller with the most math
in it of any
of any book um and so i discovered that
actually this idea is old too there's a
graduate student of andre poincare louis
bachelier
who comes from this non-traditional
background he like worked in divorce he
worked in the bond market in paris
before coming
uh before coming to study math and he
was like
look everybody's like buying and selling
and trying to understand the market but
i think it's just a random walk i think
things are just like bumping up and down
randomly
let's try to understand how that random
walk would behave and see if it matches
the behavior of the market well
again as of the biology this was
considered a little
disreputable and poincare is kind of i
get that what you're doing is good math
but it's not
the kind of math we do here in paris
like we're supposed to be studying the
free body problem in celestial mechanics
not like
bond prices um but of course now it's
the dominant point of view right i mean
if you're gonna sort of do finance if
you're gonna get a phd in finance you're
gonna be studying stochastic
differential equations
and you're gonna be like random walking
like hell
um well and by the way this this goes
back to the point you made earlier that
random doesn't mean absolutely equal
probability of everything happening
right so the stock market can trend
upward while still having a random
component
absolutely right it's like it's a it's
noise plus drift there's like a
danny kahneman's new book it's just
about this right
noise i like to talk about people's
books too um
i mean i can't even talk about it at all
because it's too long but you know and
then there's the whole einstein story
and sort of einstein is sort of like
you know ratifying boltzmann's theory of
like what the under structure of matter
is by sort of treating brownian motion
like a random walk um which i didn't
really know that much about
but then you know what we call such a
thing today we mostly call it a math
is not a random walk but a markov chain
so markov is
among mathematicians the person who
really first develops this theory and
here's the this is a story that blew me
away that i'd never heard
he invents the markov chain because
there's this huge like
theological war between this the arch
conservative
super russian orthodox russian
mathematicians
and this and the angry atheist russian
mathematicians of whom markov
was the leader and so his opposite
number a guy called mcrossof
believed that he had found a
mathematical proof of free will
kind of ratifying the views of the
russian orthodox church in this matter
and markup was like no way you can
believe what you want but don't bring
math into it like that now i'm offended
like that you would sort of say that
math proves that your
church stuff is correct so markov
develops the markov chain
as a counter example then the crossovers
uh claimed proof that free will is
implied
uh that free will is implied by
probability of theory i mean
you know i always say like you're on the
internet right i mean you know is there
anything
more intellectually sterile and unuseful
than like a long argument between like a
movement atheist and like a movement
christian right those are nothing good
ever comes out of that
no i think i i got to push back there
against uh i think that
that there's a sampling problem when
when you say that there are
loud noisy exemplars of both sides that
have very
uh not very helpful arguments between
each other but there can be
useful intellectually um productive
discussions between people who hold the
same opinions but hold them in more
productive ways
i would argue i guess you are absolutely
right but i would counter that by saying
that
in fact in terms of their personalities
markov and the crossoff were both
exactly the kind of like
loud and structural equally hopeless
people so it's amazing that out of their
dispute like came this like absolutely
fundamental mathematical idea but then
it's amazing that like none of them knew
about each other i mean this was now
right i mean now sort of math is global
but then stuff is happening in england
stuff is happening in france stuff is
happening in switzerland with einstein
and stuff is happening in russia with
markov and none of them knew it's all
happening between 1900 and 1905 and none
of them knew about each other it's
incredible
right so this is pre-russian revolution
microsoft and
uh and and markov and i do i think that
the audience deserves just a little bit
of a glimpse into
what necrosoft thought he was doing with
the free will business like he was
trying to
reconcile the idea that individuals are
allowed to have free will
even though whole societies act in
predictable ways
yeah exactly so one thing um so you
start with the law of large numbers
which is like a which has been known for
a long time which essentially
um put in terms of coin flips because
you know in probability theory the only
thing we have are coins and urns right
everything about one of those two things
so it's uh
but this one's about coins right you
flip coins for a long time
and with a very high degree of
probability the proportion of heads
you're going to get is going to get very
close to 50
for any fixed deviation from 50 the
chance that you're going to get
say 51 you certainly might get 51 heads
if you flipped 100 coins but
if you flipped a million coins that's
incredibly unlikely
um and what people started to see this
is long after bernoulli when sort of
people started to study demographic
statistics is that just as
coin flips kind of settle down to
predictable averages if there was enough
coins
so social measures like tended to
converge to predictable averages if
there was enough people
in your aggregate um and so
there was a lot of kind of philosophical
unease about what that meant did that
mean we're just all like mindless coins
we're just all like sort of like
little balls in the roulette wheel like
sort of with uh
you know you know faded in some sense
essentially deterministically to sort of
like
at least as a society like acting a
certain way well as you can imagine that
is
not a happy thought for people of
certain philosophical events and the
crossover you found a way out of this
necrosis that hey hey look this this
theorem of bernoullis this law of large
numbers
it requires that the coins be
independent from each other
um if your coins are not independent
like let's say if each in the simplest
case let's say each coin is constrained
to fall the same way as the previous one
well then you'd either get all heads or
all tails you wouldn't converse to 50
so the cross stuff said ah this law of
large numbers these statistical
regularities we see of like
you know age of first child age of first
marriage like proportion of various
crimes like all these things you see
the fact that those seem to converge to
stable averages
might have made you thought were just
mindless coins but no what it really
shows
is that we must all be independent from
one another
so aha i win yeah but there's some basic
logical flaw there
yeah it's what markov observed is that
he was mistaking the theorem for its
converse i mean bernoulli's theorem
says that if the coin flips are
independent then you get these
this convergence to stable averages but
it didn't show that if you have
convergence to stable averages
then the flips must have been
independent and so what markov showed is
that
any kind of what we now call a markov
chain or a markov process or
a random walk um that the behavior of
such a thing
um also converges to
uh predictable averages even though if
you're walking on a random where you are
today
is anything but independent where you
are yesterday because you're very close
to where you're only one step away from
where you are yesterday so they're very
very very
tightly uh connected but then you know
having
won this battle um he did all kinds of
crazy things with it he analyzed
uh eugene o'negan the famous poem by
pushkin
and sort of studied like i mean if you
treat this as
it seems crazy to think about a poem as
a random walk and he certainly knew that
a poem was not just a random walk but he
nonetheless showed that
you could um just treat it as a string
of consonants and vowels this is a very
modern kind of
computational style approach reduced
into a string of bits zeros and ones
and and showed that um you can calculate
what's the probability of
transitioning from if a letter is a
consonant what's the probability the
next letter is a vowel or the next
letter
is a consonant that's a very simple
markup chain you might say like
that cannot tell you very much about
this famous russian poem but you know
what
he was able to show that it
distinguished it from the a different
book by a different russian author that
there were like
measurably different patterns in the
markov chain just in the sequence of
consonants and vowels
because different authors have different
favorite words or different sequences of
words so
whether a consonant follows a vowel will
be different likelihoods for different
authors
okay right so and that's in some sense
the precursor to like so much of like
the natural language processing we do
today of course we do it in a much more
sophisticated way than him writing down
these kind of like
grids on pencil and paper of consonants
and vowels but well right so all the way
up towards
gpt3 right i mean this purported
artificial intelligence uh
is actually just looking for these kinds
of patterns or these likelihoods these
probabilities of different things
happening in texts and
spitting them back at us right it's in
some sense trying to find
the the markov chain that best matches
the language production it is able to
see and it's able to see a lot because
it has access to this sort of gigantic
corpus of english language text that
exists on the internet and the people
have stored
okay wait a minute what is what is the
definition of a markov chain how should
we be thinking about that or visualizing
it in our brains
yeah you should think of it as any
process
that explores a space where you're in
some state and then
i mean we can make it more complicated
than this but let's say like
the simplest thing would be to say
you're in some state
and then where you go next only depends
on where you are right now
and there might be some randomness to it
it might be that like um you know if
i'm at 5th avenue and 29th street
i'm going to walk either a block north
the blocks out the block east or block
west so there's four places i can be and
it's not deterministic maybe i
you know flip a four-sided coin like
decide which of the four ways to go
um but the point is that if i choose to
like walk
north to fifth avenue and 30th street
then my next choice
doesn't depend on the choice i just made
like all i know is that it's kind of
like having um
it's kind of like you know the movie
memento or he has amnesia at every
moment
you don't remember anything except where
you are right now and you have to decide
what to do next
based on that that's the characteristic
feature that makes a markup chain of
markup james
good but so it's it's very much like a
random walk is a generalization
of the idea of a random walk but we're
we're walking in some very abstract
space which for markov
himself was just vowel or consonant when
he was looking at
pushkin yeah right a two-point space
valid consonant
yeah and so when you're either in either
one you're either in valor you're in
consonant there's
uh the markov chain is characterized by
the probability that you'll either just
stay at val or jump to consonant right
these are so called transition
probabilities and you can already see
that this model
is not complicated enough uh to really
capture how language works because
you know maybe you're going to have two
vowels in a row but you're probably not
going to have five
yeah and this simple model cannot see
that because at each stage when you're
at a vowel there's some chance of
staying in a vowel so
you want to dress it up a little bit
more and make it a little more
complicated
yeah so the whole point of the markov
chain the markov process
is this memoryless quality it only
depends on where you are now it doesn't
remember where you've come from which
which makes the gpt something you can't
really have a conversation with that has
no recollection of what you've already
said
well no because okay i'll say this
there's a trick to this it's very
beautiful so i'm going to tell it to you
which is that let's say you're doing a
markup chain on letters but what you do
to be clever
is you say actually my markov chain is
on strings of three letters
so let's say if i'm like if i see th a
if that's for my current state probably
the most likely the next letter is t
right because i'm probably not saying
like thanos so i'm probably saying
that that's a very common word i
mentioned in the middle of um
but then your next state is not
t it's h-a-t because you're walking on
the space of three-letter sequences and
you're only allowed to lop off
the first letter of your sequence and
replace it with the new letter at the
end so this this business of mem you can
kind of build in
a certain amount of memory just by
enlarging your idea of what the state is
this is a very clever
idea and so gpt-3 or any language
generation system like the autocomplete
in your gmail
um is a little bit more than that and
like you know look i'm not confident to
say what's inside the
guts of gpt3 because despite the company
being called open ai like
we don't really know what's in it but it
definitely has
they've definitely worked hard to give
it more long-range memory
yeah than a sort of more very basic
markov game-based system that's part of
what
uh makes it cool and the important thing
for the audience is that when they're
texting and there's autocorrect or when
they're doing gmail and they're
suggesting answers that's a markov chain
at work
proposing those possible solutions to
what comes next
right it's saying here's where you are
now what's the most likely place you're
going next now i don't know about you
but i always
type something else when it starts to
suggest something i'm like well i'm
certainly not gonna say that now that
you suggested it
i'm my own man yeah but you're still
part of the overall ensemble you know
like you're gonna
you're gonna contribute to the
expectation values at the end of the day
but i'm disrupting it because it's like
oh i guess i was wrong about like
you know i'm reducing its level of
certainty and what it's doing i think
the system takes you into account
that's my prediction but okay so and
then with these markov chains uh
we have a way of generalizing the random
walk and you can see how we're coming
back to the gerrymandering right because
we're gonna have a markov chain that
represents where every place that you
are represents a map and we're going to
hop to a different map right
and then you can sort of once again the
space of
different places you might hop to is
enormously big but then you can start
talking about the ensemble and its
properties
and there will be in general a favorite
equilibrium distribution right they'll
be you know
i don't know a set of probabilities tell
me what the equilibrium distribution is
what is the simplest way to characterize
that
yeah so ideally if you run the random
walk for a long time
um you will get the sort of some
consistent answer to
how much of your rock do you spend in
each possible place
uh on the map now in the case of the
gerrymanders you're probably not going
to approach that distribution because
you're
you'd have to run it so long and you
could conceivably see like every
possible distribution which we are
probably not
doing but a very a very well-known
place that does that um is google page
rank which i think you know both of us
are old enough to remember the
incredible
difference in how the internet worked
there were search engines before google
but they did not work the way google
works
and what google did was build the markov
chain into the process basically
they did a random walk on the internet
a very good abstract base that we liked
a lot you're on a page you follow a
random link from it that's the walk
you do that for a long time and
you start to converge to a probability
distribution their sites you're hitting
again and again
which sites do you hit well it's
you might say well it must be sites that
have a lot of links to them so you're
likely to get there but it's not just
that there's something recursive about
it
because you want the sites that link to
it to themselves be sites that have a
lot of links
to them you know if i just have like two
random sites that have like a billion
links to each other
i'm never going to get into that little
closed ecosystem unless other people
link to it
so this process of random walk and then
keeping track of
what's this limiting distribution of how
much how much portion of your time to
spend at each place
that's the basis of what google called
pagerank back in the mid 90s when they
developed this
that is the order in which they serve
you your search results
and that absolutely revolutionized
people's ability
to find things because this limiting
distribution what the markov chain finds
for you and computes for you
is it's somehow a global property of the
system that it's a
very very hard it's kind of an emergent
property that it's very very hard to
sort of see in any local way
you just got to do the walk um and see
what happened
and what they saw is that it does an
incredibly good job of sort of
capturing this notion this human notion
of
importance or centrality or the search
results that i
actually want but for something like our
maps our gerrymandered maps or the maps
we were trying to show are not
gerrymandered
um i think like you said we're we don't
have the computational power
to sample every single map much less
keep coming back to the same map over
and over again there's just too many of
them so
what is the thought that makes us say
that some markov chain is going to help
us
figure out what a typical map looks like
well it
helps us well as i say we can't know for
certain what a typical map looks like
but we can know what a typical map sort
of like um
you know within a neighborhood the
starting map so i mean imagine
um a random office in some sense like
sort of particles diffusing
from a given source like if you're if
you've seen any of the many newspaper
articles with these incredibly
terrifying copic pictures of like what
the spray of
copic particles from somebody's nose and
mouth looks like who's infected
i mean it's much denser near the
person's head
and then it rapidly gets less dense as
you go farther away from the person
so you should think of it like that you
should think of it as like you may not
be seeing like the entire universe
but you're getting a pretty good sample
from the random walk of sort of like
what's going on
in the neighborhood of the map that you
started with
um but again the fact that we're not
sort of converging this unloading
distribution
it means we're not going to do what
google does we're not going to say i'm
going to rank all maps for you and tell
you which map is best the most
like the most random the most likely to
be hit but that's not
that's not the goal the goal is not to
tell you what to do the goal is to sort
of tell you what not to do the goal is
to sort of identify
when an existing map is uh
is completely an outlier so maybe the
analog of that i'm just making this up
as i go
maybe the sort of google analog would be
that would be if i claim to you hey
my home page is the most important site
on the internet
[Laughter]
and you sort of and google sort of
started its random walk from there
and walked like a billion steps and
never found its way back there
that would be a pretty good it wouldn't
necessarily tell you like what was the
most important site of the internet but
it would definitely rule out that my
homepage is the most important side of
the internet because it'd be like come
on like i walked around for like a
billion steps
i never found my way back there it can't
be that important
so what is the modern mathematical
research level problem uh in the
gerrymandering and markov chain
game is it coming up with algorithms to
uh
do these random walks or is it are we
are we ever going to get ambitious
enough to say well yeah we think we
actually can draw the maps as
mathematicians
go get out of the way politicians but
why would they agree to that
again i'm not a politician either so i'm
not going to say they should agree to it
but
but so what what is the what are the
mathematicians trying to do
so i would say i mean there's a lot of
questions in research and material
procedure based and i should i should
emphasize
i am not one of the people doing this
research i'm a popularizer of this
research and i sort of i'm
a conduit between uh you know between
mathematicians and various like
you know lawyers and commissions that
i've testified before et cetera et
cetera
um so i would say some of the things
people are doing are trying to get like
you know
better provable guarantees about like
maybe you don't know it's like a hundred
percent random or like sort of like can
you get some kind of provable guarantees
about how
close to uniformly random you are um
studying the properties of different
choices of what the local moves are this
is like very granular stuff but it turns
out to actually make a difference to
how rapidly you converge to something
that looks kind of uniform so this kind
of
you might probably have an engineering
problem just being like pri in practice
like what
short versions of the many local things
you could do actually work i mean
something that i'm particularly
interested in and i actually don't know
to work that people are working on this
but as you probably know like
around the country there is a lot of
appetite for interest in
reform of the basic voting mechanisms
themselves like people have introduced
like ranked choice voting
uh you know in maine and new york city i
think in austin today or something like
that in austin texas i think they've
just
adopted something like this um there's a
really interesting proposal with some
bipartisan support actually
here in wisconsin where the legislature
hasn't done anything for like two years
but maybe
maybe not they'll do something that has
some support for both parties so
i think a lot of the work
in gerrymandering has really focused on
conditions as they are
conditions where we have the voting
system we have and we have the two
parties we have and we don't even ignore
the existence of like
candidates or voters who don't identify
with one of those two parties
um introducing fundamental changes in
how the vote works
mike rank's choice voting is going to
scramble this a lot
both for the people drawing
gerrymandered maps and for the people
trying to detect
gerrymanders maps so one thing that just
personally i'm interested in is trying
to understand
how this landscape changes with more
variation in possible voting systems
which we're
as i say we're already starting to see
and there are states
well there's one state name that has
really like gone all in on this
mechanism and it'll be really
interesting to see how things play out
there but again doing the work is going
to be both math
and political science and law like all
mixed together if you try to do it with
one discipline by itself you can't do it
we've said it before in the podcast why
don't you just say what ranked choice
voting is
so the the folks get an idea for why it
would be an attractive thing to
shoot for oh yeah sorry sometimes i get
immersed in this voting stuff but i
forget that like
most people probably to their psychic
benefit like don't think about
democracy maintenance all the time um
so ranked choice voting means that um
you don't just vote for one candidate
and say this is the one i like best
you rank all the candidates who are on
the ballot
in order of how much you would like them
to hold the office and what that allows
you to do
um is if you are somebody who doesn't
identify strongly as a democrat or a
republican
and maybe even identifies with a third
party it allows you to vote for that
party's candidate
while not giving up your right to
express a preference between the
democrat and the republican which you
might well
uh really have you know in fact in the
proposal in wisconsin
they're talking about having ditching
partisan primaries
and just having open primary where all
the democrats and all the republicans
and all the libertarians and all the
everybody and the unaffiliated
all are in one primary the top five
finishers
go to the general election and then it's
ranked twice from there so in a
situation like that
you probably would have a general
election with multiple candidates you
might have two democrats and two
republicans and a fifth
person for example and then i think um
again i i can't do this by myself it's
my position we need political scientists
to weigh in but
intuitively you feel like it scrambles
things up and gives people more choices
in a political arena which frankly just
listening to people talk when you go to
these commissions
a lot of people are pretty frustrated
with the choices that they have
do you think that there is some future
collaboration between political
scientists and mathematicians where you
are very ambitious and say look
let's try to think about what are the
goals that we have
in electing people uh in sort of um
course graining the individuals in our
society
into a legislator legislature
and try to figure out a priori or you
know abaniccio i should say
what is the best voting system that
would reflect the actual will of the
people is that too
utopian i mean people are going to work
on it whether you think it's too utopian
or not right there's nothing too utopian
for people to think about
um no i think that those kinds of
discussions already are happening and
have
been happening look like go all the way
back to arrows theorem there's like lots
of interest in kind of like mathematical
formalisms
about not just how voting not just
analysis or existing voting but like
how voting could work right so that's
like a pretty old idea
um so what i would say maybe this is a
good opportunity because one thing i
just thought of that certainly
moonducing has told me is that you know
they see these techniques
not just as a way to sort of like give
meaningful testimony in court about a
particular
political question that's happening in
the moment but
as a sort of new kind of
tech for doing social science research
in the same way that in
physics i'm not going to talk about
physics so please tell me if i say
something like completely off base
i mean people use monte carlo
simulations
all the time to sort of simulate and try
to understand what the effect of doing a
certain thing would be in a situation
where for various reasons they can't
actually experiment isn't that
a thing um
i mean i went to a great seminar of like
a guy who's like well we're sort of
trying to figure out things about like
atomic weapons but we are not you know
we don't just like
drop atomic bombs on places where we
think not too many people live or not
too many people who are important to us
live anymore like that's not how we test
anymore like a lot of it is like
similar you know simulations based on
like pretty hardcore numerical analysis
but
also monte carlo techniques so i think
that at least some of the people in this
area envision a world in which
um you know also in political science
like experiments are like
hard to do and often ethically
questionable right
so maybe this is too utopian but i mean
there is an idea of like we could at
least get some good ideas about
what the results of sort of different
kinds of voting systems would look like
from simulations of this kind
and maybe to to wrap up on a less
utopian note because i know that you
know
as scientists and mathematicians we like
to be utopian but
as you emphasize very very properly
politicians
feet on the ground have a different set
of values and different set of cares so
one of the things you mentioned
very briefly which intrigued me was the
idea of
inventing schemes by which you can admit
that the map will be drawn by
a legislature not by an independent
commission and yet
inventing schemes where sort of like for
two kids trying to slice up the pie
uh they are are driven toward a more or
less equitable outcome
yeah i mean so this is sort of a famous
there's a very famous
problem called the cake cutting problem
which is a very elegant answer like you
know how do you
how do you cut a cake fairly into two
pieces
between two people who both want to eat
we both like cake and want a lot of cake
and um you know the way you do this is
you have like one kid cut and the other
kid chooses
so the kid who uh so somehow this
iterative process
will be separated into steps somehow
sort of creates
an incentive to like make the division
roughly fair and then there's like an
entire literature like how do you do
this if there's three kids and three
pieces four kids and four pieces like
you know multiple kids who may be able
to choose a subset of the pieces
whatever like mathematicians once we
have something
like generalized math but so yeah so one
thing that people have discussed
um is um
could there be a protocol where you make
a game
out of gerrymandering like you start
with some map but then the parties take
turns
i'll change it this way now i'll change
it now i'll change it i'll tell you
each team sort of tried to make it maybe
presumably trying to make it more
favorable to their
party now actually you have to be a
little careful of the people who write
about this there's more complicated
protocols than what i just said to make
it even possibly work
but the idea is that the reason this
might be useful
i haven't decided if i think it's
practically useful but the reason it
might be useful
is that because these it's precisely
because these highly gerrymandered maps
are so special and they're so unusual in
their own neighborhood they represent
this kind of local apex of partisan
advantage
so like imagine if there's like two kids
wrestling on top of a mountain
and one kid is trying to get you to the
top of the mountain and one kid is
trying to get you off the peak
well there's a lot more non-peak than
peak so if the two kids kind of take
turns pushing each other
they're not going to stay at the peak
they're going to be like somewhere else
that's like much farther down
so i think this is like some but i just
here we come back to something we said
at the very beginning
that the current mechanism makes it
so easy to do so much to cement your
partisan advantage that almost any
disruptive change i think would be much
more likely to improve the situation
than to make it worse
so this is a rare example where entropy
is working in our favor
kick the tv that's what i say kick the
tv and it's gonna start working again or
at least we'll work better than it works
now
i like that message thanks so much
jordan ellenberg thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast
oh thanks for having me this was great
[Music]
you